muy bien parte de explica como cualquier
aspecto del razonamiento del estudiante
identificado en la parte d está
expresado con tu relación matemática en
la parte se explica como tu relación de
la parte se podría corregir cualquier
aspecto incorrecto del razonamiento del
estudiante en la parte ve aunque parezca
algo confuso lo que quiere decir esto es
que hay que hacer explícitas las
relaciones entre el inciso c y las dos
partes del inciso b referente a las
relaciones que escribiste en la parte c
no sólo la respuesta final que obtuviste
al manipular estas relaciones vamos a
escribir aquí abajo de la parte se nos
muestra nos muestra que el duplicar
el duplicar la compresión
resulta en una mayor energía
en duplicar la compresión resulta en una
mayor energía potencial y cinética
potencial y cinética
en diferentes momentos del tiempo
incluso podríamos dibujar una línea
vemos que por acá esta línea y esta
línea
dibujó una flecha hacia estas líneas
para referenciar lo que hicimos antes y
para aclarar lo escribo entre paréntesis
u2 es igual a 4 11 dados es igual a 4
cada uno
sin embargo sin embargo ya que la
energía cinética
ya que la energía cinética es cuatro
veces mayor cuatro veces mayor y tenemos
la misma fuerza y tenemos la misma
fuerza de fricción
la misma fuerza de fricción la distancia
la distancia a la que se detiene el
bloque
distancia a la que se detiene el bloque
será cuatro veces mayor
cuatro veces mayor ok la parte se nos
muestra que el duplicar la compresión
resulta en una mayor energía potencial y
simétrica
y una mayor distancia vamos a escribirlo
aquí y una mayor distancia a la que se
detiene el bloque a la que se detiene el
bloque
otra flecha para indicar la línea que le
corresponde sin embargo ya que la
energía cinética es cuatro veces mayor y
tenemos la misma fuerza de fricción la
distancia de la que se detiene el bloque
será cuatro veces mayor y vimos esto
aquí arriba también así que lo que
decimos es que el estudiante tiene razón
en cuanto a que una mayor compresión
implica mayor energía y una mayor
distancia sin embargo esa distancia será
cuatro veces más grande no el doble de
grande vamos a escribirlo
el doble de grande
no es doble de grande y con esto
terminamos